moi samantha puis je t'avais prévenu de
toi que tu avais tort je l'avais dit
calme-toi rôle aurait dû la tuer quand
on en a eu l'occasion pour ça s'il te
plaît avant qu'ils ne descendent tous
les deux de l'adrénaline pure fallait
que je te garde éveiller quelques choses
arrivent c'est énorme et ça vient de là
d une direction toi là c'est quoi ce
truc c'est un ordre
alice
qu'est ce qu'on va faire de ce qu'on va
faire on va les tuer jusqu'au dernier
paré à faire face
à
je me souviens plus trop comment tout ça
a commencé
j'ai parfois l'impression que ça a
toujours été ma vie
pour rire
tui
je m'appelle alice et ceci mon histoire
la fin de mon histoire
il y a dix ans à raccoon city il y à une
épidémie
elle s'est répandue dans le monde entier
en quelques jours
d'une manière ou d'une autre notre monde
touche à sa fin la question est allons
nous mourir avec lui
elle a développé un antivirus il
pourrait détruire le virus t je n'ai
aucune raison de croire ce que tu dis
c'est vrai mais je peux t'offrir ce que
tu souhaites le plus c'est quoi un bon
jour il peut arrêter tout ça
autant retourner
j'étais compagne
qu'est ce qu'on va faire on va les tuer
jusqu'au dernier
sort l'artillerie j'en connais un rayon
ça fait longtemps qu'on joue tous les
deux mais la partie est finie
[Musique]
tout ce que tu as parce que c'est ça je
vais te tuer
[Musique]
à